[Musique]
bonjour messieurs dames
comment où je passe mes vacances a à g
passe à paris voir u2 au nouveau théâtre
daunou je joue le canard à l'orangé
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août
ah parce que vous croyez peut-être que
je suis dans ma superbe
résidence secondaire a pas du tout pas
du tout élargissait vous allez voir
voilà à a ça surprend ça mais regardez
je suis vraiment mieux mieux que chez
moi il fait frais il fait doux il n'y a
pas un bruit ya rien dans un ses
superbes décors d'arthur à bâle venez
voir non non on a un parc
si je veux des doubles et fenêtres
regardez donc approcher vous parce que
oui et les nuits où il fait beau par
exemple eh bien je dors là sur mon petit
matelas pneumatique
le matin j'ai mon petit camping gaz je
me fais mon petit café au lait comme à
la campagne sans les inconvénients c'est
pas super bon ça si je veux entendre des
oiseaux j'ai mon ami jean le régisseur
gens tu veut m'envoyer les oiseaux se
plaît - forains là c'est trop là parce
qu'on peut pas dormir avec ses lettres
la voyez aller demander à des oiseaux
dans la nature de la mettre en veilleuse
vous verrez eux ils vont vous répondre
tranquille ici regardez
et puis en plus tous les soirs c'est ça
qui est formidable c'est que j'allais
oublié de vous dire une chose c'est que
je suis pas seul dans la pièce je
retrouve des amis dont mylène demongeot
est une femme superbe quand vous allez
voir tout à l'heure en sortant sur la
fiche et j'avoue que d'être ici dans ce
théâtre toute la journée en se disant
que le soir il ya plein de spectateurs
qui vont venir nous voir
eh ben je vous souhaite de passer
d'aussi bonnes vacances que moi sur les
routes et sur vos plages
[Musique]